most of society's rules and traditions
are based on when people were dying at
50 years old most of the rules of when
you should get married and what you
should do and what you should have
accomplished is literally based on the
last Century's DNA you are so young you
have every opportunity technology is
exploding at a speed where your life can
change in a minute on a decision and
literally literally the only thing that
is [__] you up is you worry about
what other people think about your life
whether that's your parents your friends
stop doing that where crazy Rose suits I
like it it's very nice do random [__]
try new things you have your whole life
in front of you I couldn't be happier
for you if you're standing right now you
have 100 years to live that's actually
how it's going to work out for you and
you need to start acting like it